[Music]
you you just shot 35 because i would
have got you jim but i have a feeling
that
the big fella's free throw percentage
is really much better i saw that in the
back earlier we are going to allow you
to redeem yourself and we've look at the
backboard here has got
the logos of all the teams you played
for
no no there's there's a line right
there's a line right there
oh there we go i gotta go rebound
because there's gonna be a lot of them
where's the line right here this line
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go
let's go here enough you can actually
you have your choice your choice of
balls
balls right here which one oh what that
one you don't want this one's got a
little more
i'll take the little balls on it okay
here's here here's the question
here's the question what how many
attempts will it take before he hits one
before hits what oh less than five yeah
less less three less
three i say three wait from there
which way is the line just this line oh
no no maybe i know well maybe
five yeah seven over five over five over
five
try that one i i didn't know it was
gonna be that far away
all for two oh here you go here you go
yeah what they're building the house
over here stop moving it man
you're building the house and shaking it
shake it up
hey don't worry remember to play
to play fan duels over under david hey
guys just hold up that episode of law
and order
hey hold for five level five let me go
there
over six there you go there you go there
you go
man i've already killed two people i'm
blowing it off man just don't know don't
he's gonna break the plexis don't just
mess with hey
one for seven what's the center one one
for eight okay
very nice not bad i'm just messing with
you
that bad yeah okay that was entertaining
i told you
i know what's gonna happen no no no no
no don't break anything oh just come
here
i'll call you hey quit that's a wrap for
inside
the nba presented by kia
no
for chuck and shaq and for kenny
we actually have uh a few days off here
yes hey here's say with the snake don't
run kitty help me kenny help me
please stay here kenny yeah y'all stay
away from wild
hold me hold me diesel
don't joke about snakes man thanks again
to the bucks imperial circus for coming
by and entertaining us
uh with the burmese python everything
else drop something over there
missed it yes he did oh no but i think
he was fouled send him to the line
we got a playoff day off
we'll see you all sunday thanks crew
coming home i'm coming home